et pendant ce confinement il est parfois
difficile de trouver des produits frais
un coût raisonnable les grandes surfaces
ont du mal à soutenir les prix
augmentent alors les consommateurs sont
de plus en plus nombreux à se tourner
vers les circuits courts les petits
producteurs vins leurs commandes
gonflé et tente de répondre à la demande
reportage dans le cotentin de soul and
go dans ses dialogues argent et morgane
france au retour au port comme chaque
jour pour jean-pierre pêcheurs à
barfleur dans la manche le quotidien n'a
pas été bouleversé par le confinement
mais un changement tout de même un
véritable raz de marée de commandes mais
il ya beaucoup plus de demandes la
demande elle a multiplié par 2 3 4 5
mais c'est beaucoup plus facile de
travailler pour nos je suis tout seul
donc c'est bien évident que celui qui
l'a pas l'évidence de travailler
correctement
conséquence du confinement la vente en
circuits courts a le vent en poupe
jusqu'à paris une part de la pêche est
livré dans la capitale
alors avant le confinement on était à
peu près 20 clients par livraison donc
une livraison par semaine évidemment on
avait aussi quelques restaurants plutôt
gastrostomie castro ils ont fermé et
après maintenant là on est passé à à peu
près 150 clients par livraison donc on a
dû embaucher deux livreurs ont fait deux
rotations par semaine au lieu d'en faire
qu'une clientèle qui connaissait pas ce
type de produit aussi qualitatif et
aujourd'hui ils l'apprécient pour jean
pierre qui livre les particuliers à
domicile les gestes barrières ont
remplacé les poignées de main et les
clients se sont adaptés pour que les
livraisons puissent avoir lieu à mes
clients habituels et le téléphone sont
en jeu prend vos poissons jamais mon
poisson à la barrière et le monsieur où
la dame mais une enveloppe projeté sur
la barre y ait un engouement pour le
poisson tout juste sorti des filets qui
vaut aussi pour les légumes frais à deux
kilomètres de barfleur à montfarville le
point de vente de cette maraîchère ne
désemplit pas ici nous avons à peu près
30 à 40 % de personnes qui viennent en
plus en marché en circuit court
je pense il ya le produit sain et frais
en plus ces marchés ont été fermées et
il ya déjà des personnes qu'ils n'iront
jamais acheté leurs légumes en grande
surface parce que les jambes comme ils
veulent pas se déplacer loin et ils vont
plus au plus près voilà un changement du
mode de consommation qui pourrait bien
devenir une habitude à la fin du
confinement et concurrencer la grande
distribution